Haití al borde de una catástrofe
humanitaria Es la advertencia que lanza
este viernes el programa mundial de
alimentos de Naciones Unidas
la situación de la seguridad alimentaria
en Haití está empeorando el informe dice
que según las cifras que tenemos 4,7
millones de personas en Haití se
enfrentan a una inseguridad alimentaria
aguda de las cuales 1,8 millones se
enfrentan a niveles de emergencia de
inseguridad alimentaria
unas 19.000 personas en cité solé uno de
los barrios más pobres de Puerto
Príncipe se enfrentan a un hambre
catastrófica debido al aumento de la
violencia además unos 100.000 niños
menores de 5 años en Haití sufren de
desnutrición severa
Hace seis meses teníamos cifras más
bajas estamos viendo un aumento de
200.000 personas en situación de
inseguridad alimentaria aguda y un
aumento de medio millón de personas para
los niveles de emergencia
Hay personas clasificadas en la fase 5
Esta es la peor clasificación en la
escala de 5 puntos que actualizamos para
calificar la inseguridad alimentaria
Y es que hace un mes las bandas
haditianas impiden la distribución de
gasóleo y gasolina lo que paraliza a
negocios y hospitales sectores de Puerto
Príncipe están literalmente aislados por
las mafias que con barricadas impiden
que la capital se comunique con otras
ciudades del país la situación crea
escasez de productos básicos y vitales
como el agua y la gente lucha para poder
llegar a sus trabajos hace menos de una
semana el Primer Ministro Gabriel Ángel
propuso que fuerzas internacionales
ayudaran para luchar contra la
inseguridad el secretario general de la
ONU Antonio Gutiérrez pidió el
despliegue inmediato de una Fuerza
Armada especial sumado a esto el país
más pobre de América Latina se enfrenta
a un brote de cólera que hasta el
momento ha dejado 18 muertos y 32 casos
confirmados